[Applause]
this group of fathers have gathered
before to talk
so what's up fellas how you guys doing
doing all right man good job
yeah man thanks for coming but this time
they're taking their message public
hoping this video will spark real change
we came together today just to have a
quick conversation about
some of our feelings about about growing
up black and having our kids grow up
black
in east york and being part of the
education system
for the six men this is a place to share
experiences
and express their concerns for viewers
it's a place to listen
to learn and to understand
it was here in this park in east toronto
the dads met
and began talking over the years these
passing conversations grew into so much
more
michael avis and carrie cox are two of
the fathers in the group
we'll talk about race we'll talk about
what it's like working in the office
where you're the only one
we'll talk about all those things and
that is a bond that
with you know some of my friends who
aren't black they just don't get it
it's not their fault but they just don't
understand that kind of that
conversation
talk about politics we talk about you
know
you know being black in 2021 2021
black lives matter push for diversity
and equity and
workplace and there's some cynicism
about it some hope to do with it
what it means for our kids what it means
for us we just get into all kinds of
philosophical discussions about that
kind of stuff what originally started
out
as chance encounters has now turned into
a deep
bond a friendship each dad can depend on
when they need support you guys are
getting together
you have discourse you're talking about
what's going on and all of a sudden
covet hits and the world shuts down tell
us what
you learned from your kids learning
online during the pandemic
there was one instance where i was
observing the class and i was hearing
some things that kind of made me a
little bit uncomfortable
and the first thing i did was i sent a
whatsapp to these guys i said hey fellas
i heard this
you know what should i do and
immediately they said you need to call
it out
what were these teachers teaching that
uh kind of got your back up a little bit
first i want to preface
that i'm a teacher the teachers have my
full support
that being said i don't think that
there's proper
training for teachers to talk about race
i don't think there's proper training
for them to be able to speak
meaningfully
this poor teacher is being asked to talk
about
this and she doesn't have the training
and the understanding of how her words
can affect
her students and i i felt badly for her
but i also felt badly for
my kids when i thought what are they
thinking right now
that wasn't the only concern they had
part of this discussion that we're
having today is hoping so in march
they recorded their thoughts and emailed
the video to their kids principals and
vice principals
what were you hoping to accomplish by
putting the video out there
there's definitely going to be some
teachers out there maybe some principals
out there who are going to
appreciate that it will give them a
perspective that maybe
they hadn't thought about and it might
influence
the way they approach this next time
there's a huge disconnect in the kinds
of language
in the kinds of knowledge that educators
are having particularly white educators
but other racialized educators are
having about blackness and blackness in
canada
funke is an assistant professor in the
department of history
at the university of toronto there are
people in our school boards
there are people who are working in the
ministry of education
who are deeply invested in creating
models and creating
important language that educators need
to use and adapt
and take into the classroom but for some
reason there is this disconnect
that's because there isn't a standard
level of training for canadian teachers
that differs from province to province
so there are pockets and schools and
institutions that are doing it well
there are educators in individual
classrooms that are thinking critically
about how to address and speak to their
black students and then there are
schools that aren't doing it well and as
a result we don't have a uniform way of
understanding whether or not we're doing
it right
what i see in the work that i'm doing
now is that we seem to have taken a
major step
backwards because we can't seem to deal
with a multiplicity of issues
sadie keane has been fighting for equity
in schools for more than 50 years
she was vancouver school board's first
black trustee
and helped to write the race relations
policy in the 1980s
in terms of policy it is really easy
for institutions right now
to say oh well we've done that
that's been dealt with it's often people
who have not
been directly impacted or affected by
racism and hate who are making those
decisions
experts say canada's inability to move
the needle forward
is caused by the country's failure to
confront its long-standing history
with colonialism when colonial models
came in
education was structured around
religious based institutions
and then it starts to consolidate itself
and when it does that
it doesn't envision certain groups of
people as being part of the canadian
citizenry
and as a result racialized folks
indigenous folks
black people are excluded from those
conversations entirely
many canadians assume segregated schools
are unique to the us
but it happened in canada too one
example
ontario's common school act of 1850 led
to segregated schools
more often than not the common school
act was actually used
to separate children from classroom
spaces to
further demarcate that separation by
race
and this becomes a continuous problem
that we see even in our own
current present day schooling practices
nova scotia had legislation as well
and to some extent similar practices
were taking place in prince edward
island
new brunswick and british columbia i do
think that we need to have a complete
overhaul of our education system or
really have
a forceful conversation about
educational reform but black community
members have been talking about this
for as far as 1960s and 1970s
when they've been asking right our
curriculums to change to speak to the
black experience in
really important ways and we've not yet
been able to do that well
we need to reimagine education
there's so much that we can do right
that the opportunities for
making and supporting education to truly
be much more inclusive and dynamic
and really support them to be able to
move into a world that
is calling on all of us to be
our very best selves
it's why the dads made the video to help
provide
schools the tools to reimagine back at
the park the friends have come
together again what can you suggest they
do to change or to improve there's a lot
of questions about what the
responsibility of a black parent
or a black or brown person is in
educating people about what they should
think about and how they should speak to
people
we took it as let's give some
specific tools that educators can do to
start to make
immediate change i'd just love to see
more
you know educators that look like me
whether it's supply teachers or
for plays or musical presentations or
scientists and so on to share michael
points to the fact that the fathers are
available to help
he's a college professor carrie is an
engineer
and the others well there's an executive
a doctor
a photographer a project manager and one
has a book being released later this
year
so principals have a deep well of
resources to draw upon
be mindful of the language othering
language is damaging
using words like they or them when
referring to
different cultures and different ethnic
backgrounds
automatically excludes so we should be
talking about us
as a community and not about well they
need this and black lives matter
them it's not them it's their part of
our community they're part of
us inclusive language inclusive
literature
and representation those are three
things that we said to these principals
these are things that you can do this is
low-hanging fruit
the fathers emailed the four schools
their kids attend
at the time of our interview only one
school had acknowledged receiving the
video
and the fathers offered to help global
news contacted the schools
since then all principals have reached
out to the respective dads
where do you take this from here i don't
know
we're at a watershed moment i think
there's a lot of
awareness there's a lot of every school
has a diversity committee
it's on the radar people are aware of it
i just hope and this is the reason that
i'm here
these are not just words the fact that
you put a committee somewhere does not
mean anything if that committee doesn't
do anything
we've given this to you on a silver
platter we've said here are some easy
things that you can do to make change
i don't know what the next step is but i
hope this can start a conversation a
deeper conversation about what are we
really doing are we ticking boxes or are
we really doing something different
and that i don't have the answer to